oh my god
i feel like i can definitely see your
body language and movement here it was
wild
boom this just feels special because
they're doing a fight scene in a
different way
what's up guys we are back with another
very exciting episode of stuntman react
and now we have amy johnston joining us
today is a pleasure and honor and a
privilege hi guys hi there thanks for
having me here this nice couch so i am a
long time martial artist and a lot of
stunts and action and now acting you've
been in like the star of a couple
features right i have that's freaking
awesome thanks man you guys ready to
jump in let's do it let's do it let's go
[Music]
oh my god look at him
he looks ridiculous
they both look pretty ridiculous what
was he doing before this he was halfway
through his haircut
even try it don't do it again wasn't she
also in like operation condor yeah
cynthia rothrock was one of the her and
michelle yo were kind of very prominent
in 80s hong kong
wonder if they had her do it if they had
a stunt oh they definitely had a stunt
person
yeah that's just some other dude with a
wig i don't think he would have wanted
to kick her
that hard like that's full-on dang
ouch the stuntman was probably going to
use the chair as like a cushion to break
his fall but he went over the over the
chair it's called a taco taco fall okay
that's when your legs go you can see
like tape markers too with where the
chair is supposed to be playing center
goes up yeah you're right
dude this little expression from samuel
right here love it
[Laughter]
she's fine just shrug it off yeah
literally
[Music]
oh man oh no you don't need that
position
[Applause]
that's above the head that was above the
head right
i need to pull out
i feel that oh my god
that one looked like there was some real
pain
he did the full arch he did a full
bridge usually kind of like roll over to
your side and you go
she was probably padded up right uh that
was definitely padded if you're going to
get hulk smashed by samo
you should pad dang yeah agreed so what
do you think's worse that or the
sidekick
oh that 100 because the side kick you
can like
have a little more control this is just
a full smash onto your back have you had
any broken bones
no i've torn my acl how long the acl
take to recover from six months
was that part of a shoot yeah it was
right before the lady blood fight was my
first like feature film as an actress
brief
there's a lot of differences in filming
like hong kong action compared to
american action america we have a lot of
like amazing pads and things that we do
here i remember the first day i got to
set they had like a hello kitty pad that
was like this small for a stunt pad and
i was like where do you guys have pads
we're like yeah yeah yeah we have we
have all these pads
cool
they kind of just have their way of of
doing things
straight up
runs up and punches you he's like
winding up he wind it from like
four spots back i don't know when i
still didn't see him i should have heard
him
[Laughter]
oh dang i should have tipped that's [ __ ]
15
if you are enjoying the show and you
want to see more of these episodes
please consider subscribing to the
corridor crew channel helps us out and
helps you out because we get you the
videos you want even quicker so outside
of filming you for real doing fight
scenes you've also been filmed by
computers
yeah what i mean by that is you've done
motion capture for video games yeah so i
do motion capture for a lot of video
games basically you get into that onesie
suit with a bunch of balls that are on
your joints and different areas of your
body and they have a reflective surface
so there's a bunch of cameras in the
volume which is where we record motion
capture and those cameras are picking up
the reflectors on the balls and then
syncing it into the computer and then
you have like a real-time um animation
of my character movements that you can
link to like the actual character that's
designed it's freaking cool so you don't
have to worry about makeup you don't
have to worry about no it's the best you
just get a play
i've come so far a lot of these stunts
what i'm actually doing is in the stage
i'm running i'm jumping off of an apple
box and i have an actual ice pick in my
hand and there's a bar above me and so i
run i jump off that and i ice pick the
bar and like hang it's wild
and like climbing with the ice pick it
was wild
i'm not turning back
and that we were cheating
like that my body being horizontal like
that all i did was somebody was holding
a rope and i held the other side of the
rope and then i leaned my body over and
went back and forth on the volume and
tried to like have the momentum of going
from one side to the other like quick
quick quick slow quick quick slowly just
running on the ground running on the
ground yeah
and do you have to land on solid ground
or incorporate pads so the amazing thing
with motion capture is you can
incorporate pads because you don't see
them yeah so you can have all of these
things that you want to play with like
mini tramps and anything your heart
desires it's like a playground
so that was a trailer and i did all our
all our movements for that but then in
the game there's multiple people
performing the the movements as well as
the voice actors
so a lot of times like the motion
capture performers will do all of the
movement set and the voice over artists
will just record when everything is done
and they can record over it
other studios have the actors on set
while you're doing the movement and um
they're saying the lines while you're
doing the movement or sometimes they do
the movement it's
different with different studios
i feel like i can definitely see your
your body language movement here in this
fight scene like that wasn't me that
wasn't you i'm kidding
i'm like dang yeah it's really cool to
see like when i'm moving or like if i
know how my friend runs i'm like oh
that's so and so
i always geek out when i get to do
lightsaber stuff though and like for
fall and order i did a lot of a lot of
stuff on that so fun to try to make it
look different because we've seen a lot
of swirly
twirly lightsabers we've seen the more
gritty and i wanted to well we wanted to
use like each other's weapons on each
other and i like pulled a knife out of
one guy's back and threw it at the other
guy wanted to really work with what i
had there so there's no there's no one
with like a fake camera or like a motion
tracked like viewfinder on set when
you're doing this um sometimes there is
some sometimes they'll bring in the
actual uh camera to to see the
environment as we're going through the
scene to get an idea of like where they
want the movements it's pretty amazing
technology and they can make you jump
like 20 feet higher awesome if you guys
are like i have a scene that i want you
guys to talk about we'll get a
professional on and we'll talk about
that scene because we love reading your
comments comment or die
right
right okay
[Music]
i always love group fights because
everyone in the background is doing the
ultimate putty of like
where does that putty term come from
power rangers there it is
[Music]
you've had to take falls like that
before right yeah thankfully now we have
a lot of great padding that we can place
gator backs and things to protect our
spine but in like the earlier days and a
lot of hong kong cinema like they really
didn't use much padding a lot of people
say like you know i could fall to be a
stunt person it's not about like if you
can it's can you do it multiple times
and hit your mark and still like act out
the scene um that's what that's what a
stunt person does so how do you take a
fall like that and minimize
your pain um first you have a good
partner that knows how to throw you so
like jackie knows what he's doing
because he's a stunt guy he knows how to
throw people in the right position it's
just about landing in certain areas of
your body like the more meaty parts of
your body more muscle to protect you uh
stay away from your bones and you never
want to be too tight to where your
body's like tense
you guys have taken falls i've seen you
guys do things we did a scene together
we did a scene together what do we do oh
this is sorry
oh my god what did we do
what did we do we like trained a week
for it and like you know
it was like you know where it is i
remember working with you guys i don't
remember what oh this is great i've
worked like a few times oh [ __ ] let's
put it up
we did that thing this tip jar episode
tip chart yes yes
okay yes okay
[Music]
it's not a bunch of crazy stunts but it
was really intense because it was all in
one take yeah this was fun i really like
this it actually made sense for a one
take as well yeah agreed a lot of people
are obsessed with one takes but most of
the time it doesn't make sense
there's some solid like slapstick black
and white definitely going for that
chaplin vibe yes
[Music]
you kicked me i know but the kick didn't
connect though
did you want it to connect i mean it
sort of looked like it connected right
[Music]
yeah we did like 10 bottle breaks in a
row do those fake bottles hurt the
softer somebody hits you with it the
harder it hurts so i've had actors that
like are afraid to hit you with the
bottom like it's breakable the last
thing you want to do is not go for it
please go for it so we can do this once
and and get it done
how many takes did this take you guys i
think it took us like three times this
is an impressive long take guys yeah
i love this scene it's great it was fun
we totally did a scene together yeah
yeah you totally forgot about the scene
[Music]
pizza
[Music]
oh they're imagining the fight yeah
it's in their head right now isn't that
beautiful choreography yeah it's hard to
like define
what makes choreography good what do you
think i feel like it's a conservation of
movement like you know when you hit then
your next move should be a bounce a
rebound and like into something else but
also you still come with like clever
moves like it's hard to be like how can
you cleverly block a sword like i feel
like a lot of the lightsaber fight in
episode one of star wars like had those
clever moves in it but also seeing like
power like you know the spear bending
and stuff the power hits oh yeah
oh wow
i love that
look at this dodge he does right here
right
right there you can see it it's crazy
better dodge that
would you trust donnie to come at you
with a spear yeah i'd trust them i mean
even i got clipped it'd be cool to say
that donnie and stabbing him stop me
how'd you lose your eyes oh yeah yeah
something that's really subtle in this
fight scene is that they've enhanced the
weapons so they glow and really stand
out they're turning into like
lightsabers you can really follow them
with your eyes and see every move
oh is it just one move that ends it
that's great you get the full fight
scene and then it's just this one master
move at the end yeah because he figured
out all of his attacks and his counter
attacks right this just feels special
because
they're doing a fight scene in a
different way with amazing choreography
but it's packaged in this
very interesting like uh story beat you
know
the two artists who are performing the
choreography is really what makes it
special because their movements are
great and perfectly timed they're not
always just going straight attacks like
they're using the environment they're
going for each other's legs not just the
head they're able to perform specialty
moves but still have it make sense for
attacks
are they imagining the same thing
i don't know because what's donnie yen's
version of this like is he is he winning
or are they both so in tune well no
they're both listening to the same song
and the musicians dictating the flow of
the fight
the flow of the fight sure
are in one one mind in one mind maybe we
should film what's in the other mind
that'd be so funny
[Laughter]
well sometimes when you order your merch
to be restocked uh two months ahead of
time well sometimes the restock happens
in the middle of a virus pandemic when
10 million people file for unemployment
but hey guess what codeword
digital.store has been restocked so if
you are one of those out there who's
fortunate enough to still be working
working from home you're looking for
something comfy to impress anybody else
who's also in the house with you in
isolation head on over to corridor
digital.store we actually just restocked
a bunch of our most popular things we
have the corridor digital green screen
blanket back in stock so that not only
keeps you warm throw it up behind you
and make it look like you are in a fancy
office or on a beach or on a mountain we
also have the motion capture crew neck
back in stock we have the joggers back
in stock which are a very very popular
item they tend to sell out in like an
hour we have a new yellow long-sleeve
shirt we have some backpacks left a
whole bunch of good stuff i'm here to
tell you guys that this stuff is really
high quality stuff each piece we sell is
going to be lasting you for years and
see here this this corridor onesie on
baby gwen well this thing is going to
last for years too i bet when she goes
off to college she's going to have this
on her back lastly there's free returns
on everything so if you know something
doesn't fit don't sweat it set it on the
back we'll cover all the costs you know
in the future uh when
when we get back on our feet we'll make
sure to restock all these things once
again should any of them sell out so
that those of you who want an
opportunity to buy these but are saving
your money right now well we'll have
another opportunity again but for
everybody else out there if you happen
to want any of this stuff it's in the
store right now waiting for you corridor
digital dot store go check it out
so you know it's crazy amy actually
wrote a book called how to stunt in
hollywood and she did all the hard work
for you guys she went on set and she
went visit all of her friends and she
asked her friends all the questions that
you guys would ask and compiled it into
a nice little book it's actually on
amazon you guys can pick it up if you
guys want to follow more of amy's work
she's on instagram amy e johnston so
head over give her some love thanks for
coming out and doing this yeah thank you
guys it's been super fun yeah absolutely
i feel like we should fight now